Texas in the White House are locked in a
bitter standoff On the Border the
administration demanding Texas reopen a
border Park to federal agents after the
drowning deaths of three migrants the
White House blames Texas for those
deaths saying the state blocked Agents
from rescuing the women excuse me the
woman and her two children but a new doj
court filing has disproved that
narrative revealing the migrants were
already dead when the feds requested
access meanwhile Texas is holding firm
and refusing to let the feds back in
they don't tell us where they're sending
people where people are coming across
they don't tell us about criminal
activity along the border they don't
tell us who they're letting in whether
it's terrorists or people that have
committed crimes they don't tell us
where people are from we have the
obligation to control public lands in
Texas we're a sovereign state and we
plan on defending our borders more on
this with Texas lieutenant governor Dan
Patrick but first let's go to Matt Finn
he's in Eagle Pass with the latest hi
Matt good good morning Dana yesterday
was the deadline the federal government
gave to Texas to reopen this park back
to border patrol agents as it stands
this morning we have not seen Texas
allow the federal government back into
this park and Texas DPS tells me that's
because Texas feels it is just better at
deterring migrants from crossing the
river here into this park because Texas
feels the Biden Administration wants an
open border we're trying to prevent
illegal border crossing so that we don't
see this Los of life it's not normal
it's not uh Humane for anyone to cross a
river including children but it kind of
contradicts what we're trying to do and
it really shows how the federal
government is attacking Texas for trying
to prevent that because what they want
to do they want to keep the Border
open as part of Governor Abbott's
emergency declaration the state of Texas
is also now arresting migrants who
illegally cross into this park and this
state and we just want to tell you from
our observation on the ground that is a
massive change in procedure in this park
because for nearly 3 years leading all
the way up to this past December
migrants have not only been able to
freely cross the river into this park
sometimes they were ushered across the
river by the United States and then
processed by border patrol which is part
of the reason Texas says it kicked out
Biden's border agents Texas says Border
Patrol was a magnet for illegal
immigration because migrants were able
to stand in Mexico and actually see
other migrants who crossed and were
being processed here in the park
however border patrol argues being
kicked out of the park reduces the
ability for Texas and the federal
government to respond to emergencies to
save lives and we want to briefly remind
you why this particular Park is such a
Battleground just last month there was a
historic surge of migrants that
illegally crossed into this very
property overwhelming border patrol and
the state of Texas and actually forcing
the closure of legal ports of Entry now
this morning a much different scene as
we're standing here Texas has heavily
fortified this park put up razor wire
all along the river and we are seeing
Texas National Guard actually push back
migrants saying do not enter here into
the United States Dana what a situation
Matt fin thank you I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm me leart and click
here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis